Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Confine.
Cum, finis: "Con i limiti".
O meglio: "Avere in comune i limiti",
avere in comune i confini.
Il confine è qualcosa che separa;
ma soprattutto - e anzi,
prima di tutto - che unisce.
Fermiamoci un attimo a riflettere.
Siamo abituati a pensare ai confini
come a linee sul terreno
che separano i mondi,
che stanno lì a indicare
chi sta dentro e chi sta fuori,
chi è più simile a noi
e chi è più diverso da noi.
Le persone con cui
condividiamo esperienze,
le persone con cui
dobbiamo condividere le risorse
stanno tutte al di qua di quella linea;
gli altri, fuori.
È incredibile come siamo capaci
di materializzare idee.
Perché a pensarci bene, né io né voi
abbiamo mai visto linee sui confini.
Abbiamo visto cippi, semmai;
abbiamo visto muri;
abbiamo visto filo spinato.
Tutto quello che l'essere umano
ha saputo costruire per dividere,
tutto quello che l'essere umano
ha avuto bisogno di costruire,
quando ha avuto bisogno di dividere.
E se per dividere su un confine
è necessario mettere un cippo,
costruire un muro, mettere filo spinato,
è perché il confine non è sufficiente,
di per sé, a dividere,
perché il confine potrebbe unire.
Può sembrare un paradosso,
ma la Storia ci insegna che non lo è.
I confini erano continuamente attraversati
da persone, oggetti, credenze, idee.
E questo può farci molta paura.
Mi chiamo Elena Franchi,
e di mestiere faccio la storica.
Insegno una storia molto lontana:
quella degli antichi greci.
Ma come tutti gli storici,
mi piace studiare anche i problemi
che sento a me più vicini,
quelli che avverto come più urgenti:
e sono quelli che studio con più passione.
E da qualche anno, mi sono messa
a studiare il tema dei confini;
e in particolare, il tema dei confini
degli Stati federali.
Penserete: oddio,
adesso ci fa una lezione.
Vi tranquillizzo subito.
Le lezioni le faccio alle mie studentesse,
e ai miei studenti,
in un luogo molto diverso da qui
e molto lontano da qui:
le aule dell'Università di Trento,
dove appunto insegno Storia Greca antica.
Oggi qui mi limito a dirvi l'essenziale.
La storia greca antica
non è solo la storia di due città,
la storia di Atene e Sparta.
No.
In Grecia antica esistevano, anche,
degli stati federali.
Più di uno: erano moltissimi!
E questi Stati federali
avevano dei confini,
anzi delle zone confinarie.
E un giorno stavo studiando dei documenti
e mi sono imbattuta in delle fonti
che raccontavano delle storie strane,
bizzarre, a tratti anche tragiche,
ma avevano un qualcosa in comune.
Questo "qualcosa"
era che erano incentrate su dei confini
che invece che dividere univano.
Lasciate che ve ne racconti una.
Vi dicevo: in Grecia antica
esistevano anche degli stati federali.
Qui lasciatemi fare un po' la prof:
beh, insomma,
non erano proprio degli stati federali
nel senso moderno del termine;
ma insomma, ci assomigliavano molto.
E vi dico subito
che il mio stato federale preferito
è quello dei Focidesi:
la Focide, nel cuore della Grecia.
I focidesi hanno lottato anima e cuore
per il proprio territorio,
e hanno anche cercato
di espandersi oltre i confini.
E questo, ovviamente,
li ha portati a entrare in tensione
con i loro vicini, anche in conflitto.
E questo è accaduto, anche,
con i vicini che stavano più a sud:
i beoti, gli abitanti della Beozia.
Vedete, focidesi e beoti
avevano in comune una zona di confine;
e quindi,
mi aspettavo di leggere storie
di battaglie, di guerre, sangue.
E non che queste mancassero, figuriamoci.
Ma proprio per questo
mi sono stupita, a maggior ragione,
di trovare anche storie di condivisione,
o addirittura di unione.
E tutte erano incentrate
intorno a un individuo di nome Foco.
Chi era Foco?
Lo avete già capito:
Foco era l'antenato dei focidesi,
era il capostipite dei focidesi.
Era il loro eroe,
l'eroe fondatore dei focidesi.
Un eroe talmente importante,
che i focidesi raccontavano
moltissime storie su Foco.
E una di queste è la storia
dell'amore tra Foco e Antiope.
Antiope era una principessa tebana:
dunque, era la figlia del re di Tebe.
Ora, Tebe è la città
più importante della Beozia.
I Beoti, quelli che stanno
a sud dei focidesi,
in conflitto per i confini.
Bene: la storia racconta
che Antiope, prima ancora
di incontrare Foco, è incinta:
aspetta due gemelli.
E questa gravidanza è il frutto
di quella che noi oggi definiremmo
una relazione illegittima.
Ragione per cui Antiope
veniva perseguitata, a Tebe;
al punto che dovette andarsene
in un'altra città a partorire.
Ma una volta dati alla luce i gemelli,
Antiope ha nostalgia:
vuole tornare a casa, torna a Tebe.
Si aspetta di non essere più perseguitata:
ha dato alla luce
gli eredi al trono di Tebe.
Ma non è così:
continua a essere perseguitata.
E la persecuzione è talmente accanita
che Antiope impazzisce.
Diventa folle - questo dice la storia -
e comincia a vagare per la Grecia
in preda alla sua follia e al suo dolore,
e vaga verso nord.
Oltrepassa il confine
tra la Beozia e la Focide,
si trova in Focide e incontra Foco.
I due s'innamorano, Antiope guarisce.
Si tratta, chiaramente,
di una storia mitica, di un mito.
Cioè di una di quelle storie
che i greci raccontavano
e riraccontavano nei secoli,
per rappresentare -
ma anche per elaborare -
i grandi temi dell'esistenza,
quelli che sono ancora per noi
i grandi temi dell'esistenza:
felicità, dolore, odio, amore,
vita, morte -
confini.
Nel nostro caso, abbiamo una storia
che racconta che l'eroe
fondatore dei focidesi
s'innamora della figlia del re del nemico.
E questo, nel mito, può accadere
perché i confini che li dividevano
in realtà non li dividevano.
Nel mito, quei confini potevano
continuamente essere oltrepassati.
Di più: su quei confini
accadevano cose che si condividevano,
accadevano cose che univano.
E che cosa unisce di più, se non l'amore?
Gli antichi greci,
questo, lo sapevano bene:
e non si limitavano a raccontare storie
di condivisione sui confini.
No: celebravano anche riti oltre confine,
e uno di questi riti riguarda ancora
i nostri due eroi innamorati,
Foco e Antiope.
Infatti, il seguito del mito racconta
che Foco e Antiope muoiono,
e muoiono a Titorea.
Guardate che Titorea
non è una città a caso:
il mito non sceglie mai, a caso.
Titorea è una città
che si trova in Focide;
ma si trova nella parte
più a sud della Focide,
quindi siamo di nuovo vicino
alle zone confinarie con la Beozia.
Ebbene, Foco e Antiope,
che sono sepolti a Titorea,
sono talmente importanti,
per i focidesi e per i beoti,
che dopo la loro morte
Focidesi e beoti assieme
organizzano un rito
per ricordarli, per commemorarli.
E questo rito viene praticato
con cadenza regolare una volta all'anno.
In cosa consisteva questo rito?
Gli abitanti di Titorea,
una volta all'anno,
andavano in missione verso sud:
oltrepassavano il confine
tra la Focide e la Beozia.
E arrivavano a Tebe, nella città
più importante della Beozia.
A Tebe arrivavano, si recavano
alla tomba dei gemelli di Antiope -
che nel frattempo erano morti -
e cercano in tutti i modi
di rubare terra da quella tomba
per portarla, rivarcando il confine,
a Titorea, in Focide.
I Tebani, dal canto loro -
questo prevede il rito -
devono cercare in tutti i modi di evitare
che quella terra venga rubata.
Questo rituale, se ci pensate,
ha dell'incredibile.
Perché mette in scena, contemporaneamente,
la divisione ma anche la condivisione.
Rubare la terra, e cercare
di impedire di rubarla,
sta per rubare il territorio,
sta per contendersi il territorio,
contendersi i confini:
viene messa in scena
una contesa, una battaglia,
se non addirittura una guerra.
Ma per organizzare il rituale,
per praticarlo -
ricordiamoci: una volta all'anno,
con cadenza regolare -
è necessario mettersi d'accordo.
Focidesi e beoti
dovevano mettersi d'accordo,
per organizzare questo rituale
in modo che tutto funzioni.
Dovevano cooperare.
Essi cooperavano
per organizzare un rituale
che mettesse in scena
la loro rivalità, e così temperarla.
Per ricordarsi che era molto più
ciò che avevano in comune,
che non ciò che li divideva.
E per non dimenticarlo,
neanche nei momenti in cui la tensione
rischiava di esplodere in una guerra,
pensavano a quel loro antenato
che si era innamorato
della figlia del nemico.
E varcavano il confine
per praticare un rito assieme,
uniti, al cospetto degli dei,
perché "cum finis", sui confini,
possono accadere cose che uniscono.
Grazie.
(Applausi)